[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ravi de vous retrouver sur Public Sénat
à suivre cet après-midi un débat sur le
thème de la désertification médicale
c'est un débat qui est inscrit à l'ordre
du jour à la demande des sénateurs
communistes c'est un thème
particulièrement d'actualité il y a une
semaine jour pour jour Xavier Bertrand
recevait des syndicats des médecins
libéraux pour tenter de revaloriser la
médecine de proximité le ministre de la
Santé entend pour cela s'appuyé sur les
propositions du rapport d'éliisabeth
Hubert l'ex-ministre de la santé dans
son rapport elle préconise la création
de maisons de santé pluridisciplinaire
car il faut dire que les jeunes médecins
et notamment les femmes refusent de plus
en plus d'exercer de façon isolée mais
la création de ces maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaire permettra-t-elle de
rééquilibrer la démographie médicale
élément de réponse avec ce
débat la parole est tout d'abord à
l'orateur du groupe qui a demandé ce
débat Monsieur Bernard verra pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyens
et des sénateurs du Parti de Gauche vous
avez la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre
mes chers
collègues le fait que notre assemblée
puisse débattre aujourd'hui de la
médecine de de
proximité en dehors de toute loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale ou de
l'examen d'un projet ou d'une
proposition de loi portant sur le sujet
n'est ni anodin ni sans conséquence les
conseillers municipaux les maires les
conseillers généraux ou
régionaux que nous représentons
les territoires et les populations qui
les habitent tout nous invite à poser
clairement cette question afin de
rechercher par tous les moyens à
garantir l'accès de toutes et de tous à
une médecine de proximité de qualité et
j'ajoute car ce n'est pas sans
importance à tarif
opposa la manière avec laquelle le Sénat
s'est
approprié les débats de la loi Hôpital
patients santé et territoire le fait que
la PR prre proposition de loi attendant
à la modifier soit d'origine
sénatoriale bien que nous soyons loin de
l'approuver me confirme dans l'analyse
que nous dressons et qui a conduit à
notre groupe qui a conduit notre groupe
pardon à proposer ce débat le Sénat en
effet toute légitimité pour aborder deux
fronts cette question et beaucoup reste
à faire d'autant que Madame Roseline
Bachelot a décidé à l'occasion du
congrès de médecine générale qui s'est
tenu à Nice en juin dernier de renoncer
à deux mesures sensées lutter contre les
problèmes de démographie médicale pour
mémoire il s'agissaient des contrats
santé solidaires et des déclarations
préalables d'absence de mesures à nos
yeux peu efficace si nous avons toujours
douté de la capacité de ces deux seules
mesures à répondre aux besoins de nos
concitoyens nous ne pouvons que
regretter la manière dont celles-ci ont
été écartées je crois madame la ministre
qu'il n'est pas de bonne
politique que le gouvernement décide
seul de sursoir à l'exécution d'une
mesure législative adoptée par la
représentation nationale surtout lorsque
ces mesures étaient censé améliorer les
droits des habitants des territoires qui
souffrent d'une sous-densification
médicale ce gel trouvera sans doute sa
conclusion par la suppression de ces
mesures comme le propose notre collègue
le sénateur Fourcade au motif que le
gouvernement et sa majorité veulent
témoigner de leur confiance aux
professionnels de santé pendant ce
temps-là nos concitoyens peinent
toujours plus dans leur recherche de
médecins de proximité et pour reprendre
les propres termes de madame Isabelle
Hubert qui a remis il y a peu un rapport
concernant la désertification médicale
je cite l'état démographique de cette
profession fait peser un réel danger sur
toute l'offre de santé c'est dire Madame
la Ministre s'il y a urgence à agir plus
plus les réponses tardent à venir plus
les difficultés auxquelles font face nos
concitoyens sont grandissantes car si la
densité médicale était de 275
généralistes pour 100000 habitants en
1985 et 340 praticiens en
2005 toutes les études prévoient à
l'horizon de 2025 une densité médicale
de 283 généralistes pour 100000
habitants soit un taux à peine supérieur
à celui du milieu des années
80 et ce bien entendu alors que le
vieillissement de la population les
souffrances liées au travail les
pathologies consécutives aux pollutions
ou tout simplement les évolutions
démographiques ont fait naître des
besoins nouveaux qu'il faudra bien
satisfaire mes chers collègues au vu de
ces éléments et alors que le nombre de
médecins y compris de médecins de
premier recours n'a jamais été aussi
grand il serait erroné de considérer que
seul un problème de démographie se pose
aujourd'hui une erreur derrière laquelle
il est est aisé de se cacher pour
renoncer à agir sur la vraie
problématique celle à nos yeux de la
régulation géographique en revanche il n
aura il y aura bien demain un vrai
problème de démographie avec un manque
criant de médecins généralistes dont les
patients seront les victimes selon les
atlasses régionaux de la santé le nombre
total des médecins en activité devrait
en effet diminuer de 10 % à l'horizon
2025 à plus ou moins long terme l'enjeu
auquel nous sommes confrontés est donc
bien l'accès de toutes et de tous à des
soins de proximité une ambition loin
d'être réalisée dans la mesure où
actuellement selon un sondage réalisé
par le collectif interassociatif sur la
santé le 6 et l'institut de sondage via
Voice 10 % des Français affirment déjà
avoir des difficultés à trouver près de
chez eux un médecin généraliste un
pourcentage qui atteint 27 % dès lors
qu'il s'agit de médecins spécialiste et
qui explose à 34 % pour l'accès à des
professionnels de santé ne pratiquant
pas le dépassement
d'honorair cette situation est alarmante
alors qu'il y a actuellement 214000
médecins en activité soit une
progression de 22 % du nombre de
professionnels depuis les années
90 dans le même temps la population
française ne progressait elle que de 10
%. ainsi la répartition inégale sur le
territoire des médecin constitue bien la
principale difficulté à laquelle sont à
ce jour confrontés nos
concitoyens selon les données recueillis
dans les 23 atlaces régionaux de la
démographie certaines régions
connaissent une réelle pénurie quand on
observe dans d'autres une
surdensification on notera par exemple
que la région Provence Côte d'Azur
arrive en tête de la densité médicale
avec 3675 médecins généralistes en
activité pour 100000 habitants contre à
peine 164 pour la région pas de caletis
cette situation résulte principalement
du fait que de nombreux jeunes médecins
récemment diplômés ont pendant longtemps
fait le choix d'une installation non
dans leur région d'origine mais dans
celle où la qualité de vie est
considérée comme
meilleure pourtant pour autant
l'implantation des professionnels dans
ces régions à forte densité médicale est
également inégale en interne si Onon
observe une importante densité le long
de la côte dans l'arrière-pays des
régions entières sont pratiquement
abandonnées de la même manière s'il est
vrai que les départements ruraux
souffrent le plus des déserts m médicaux
les départements urbains y compris parmi
les plus plus peuplés souffrent
également de cette situation à titre
d'exemple si Paris compte 742
généralistes pour 100000 habitants ils
sont SEP fois moins nombreux en scène
SaintDenis et mon département
lesesson fait face à une diminution du
nombre de praticiens en activité de 27,5
% par rapport à l'année dernière
conséquence du vieillissement des
médecins en exercice et d'un nombre
insuffisant d'installations on le voit
bien les déserts médicaux actuels sont
donc moins dusû à une pénurie médicale
qu'à une régulation inefficace ou plutôt
devrais-je dire à une absence de
régulation la liberté de d'installation
que vous défendez conduit on le voit
bien et donc consitoien nos concitoyens
le vivent quotidiennement notamment dans
les terroires dans les territoires
ruraux et les zones urbaines sensibles à
des conditions à des conditions d'accès
aux soins
inacceptables les mesures incitatives et
volontaristes que vous n'avez eu de
cesse de proposé depuis plus de 10 ans
ont fait la preuve de leur
inefficacité votre refus d'adopter
d'autres mesure plus contraignante seul
capable de garantir dans le temps et
dans l'espace une implantation médicale
adéquate aux besoins en santé des femmes
et des hommes de notre pays confine à
l'irresponsabilité je ne prendrai que
deux exemples celui des bourses
régionales et celui des aides délivrées
par l'État et l'assurance maladie et
plus spécifiquement l'avenant 20 de la
convention médicale qui accorde une
majoration de 20 % des honoraires des
généralistes exerçant en zone
déficitaire et en groupe mode d'exercice
d'ailleurs plébiscité par les
médecins cette mesure n'a absolument pas
permis de réduire les déserts médicaux
selon une étude menée conjointement par
le 6 la FNAT et l'UNAF sur 100 caisses
primaires seul 28 d'entre elles ont mis
en œuvre les dispositions contenues dans
cet avenant dans 17 Caisses sur 28
l'application de ce dispositif s'est
tout de même finalisé par une baisse de
la densité médicale alors que
l'incitation financière l'accompagnant
est de l'ordre de 25 à 28000 € annuel et
par médecin un complément de
rémunération pourtant non négligeable
quant à l'attribution de bourse
régionale en contrepartie d'une période
d'exercice obligatoire dans la
collectivité de financement celle-ci
constitue certes une première étape
intéressante mais largement insuffisante
insuffisante car elle repose là encore
sur le volontariat et sur la capacité de
financement des régions lesquelles
subissent de plein fois une politique
marquée d'abord et avant tout par une
réduction des des ressources dont elles
disposent et donc par une compression
des dépenses insuffisante également car
elle entérriine la suppression d'un
principe fondamental pour notre groupe
celui de l'égalité d'accès aux soins
entre tous nos concitoyens
indépendamment de leur lieu de résidence
ou de leurs moyens
financiers insatisfaisante enfin car
dans le même temps où le gouvernement
plaide en faveur de l'installation
volontaire des professionnels de santé
dans les territoires qui en manquent
cruellement il pratiquent une casse
méthodique et organisé de l'ensemble des
services publics fermeture des écoles
des postes des maternités des
gendarmeries et des hopitaau de
proximité reconnaissons mes chers
collègues qu'il est tout de même
paradoxal de proposer à des jeunes
médecins de s'installer dans des
territoires que que l'État abandonne
lui-même peu à
peu c'est
pourquoi c'est votre point de vue chers
collègu c'est pourquoi nous sommes
convaincus sans remettre totalement en
cause ce principe auquel les professions
libérales sont attachées qu'il est
aujourd'hui indispensable de limiter les
nouvelles installations dans les zones
déjà fortement pourvues de Médecins sans
anticiper sur l'intervention de ma
collègue Nicole borveau il me semble que
nous devrions nous inspirer des
mécanismes législatifs qui existent déjà
actuellement dans certaines professions
de santé je pense par exemple à ceux
concernant l'ouverture des officines ou
à la régulation de la démographie
infirmière de même nous devrions rendre
opposable le schéma régional de
l'organisation des soins ambulatoires
fixant par bassin les besoins en santé
des populations mais il faudra également
comme nous y invite le rapport uber
trouver les réponses structurelles et à
long terme pour éviter que dans l'avenir
ne se généralisent les déserts médicaux
cela exige de donner à la médecine de
proximité et singulièrement de premier
recours toutes ces lettres de noblesse
la reconnaissance de la médecine
générale comme une spécialité ainsi que
la possibilité ouverte au praticiens
titulairire du diplôme de médecine
général de percevoir des honoraires
similaires à ceux des autres
spécialistes pourrai constituer des
facteurs déterminants dans le choix des
étudiants en faveur de la médecine
générale à condition que cette filière
soit réellement soutenue et que le
gouvernement prenne l'ensemble des
mesures nécessaire à la création de
véritaable service universitair de
médecine générale ambulatoire force de
constater que nous en sommes encore loin
et que pour reprendre l'expression
retenue par remémy Sean et Marie kezer
dans un article paru le 8 juin dernier
dans la revue pratique l'enseignement de
la médecine générale est encore au
milieu du gay j'en veux pour preuve le
nombre encore trop faible de professeurs
titularisés par la commission
d'intégration à peine 20 quand les
représentants des enseignants de
médecine générale estiment nécessaire de
titulariser au plus vite plus de 30
professeurs associés dont les statuts
sont particulièrement précaires par
ailleurs compte tenu du faible nombre de
nomination par la voie normale de la
Convention nationale des
universités se pose sans doute la
question de la prolongation de la durée
de vie de la commission d'intégration
initialement prévue pour 5 ans
revaloriser la médecine générale suppose
un préalable indispensable qui
aujourd'hui fait défaut une véritable
professionnalisation et une
revalorisation de la formation initiale
des futurs médecins autant d'éléments
indispensables qui supposent comme le
demande des associations représentant
les étudiants de médecine générale que
l'on accorde enfin à la filière
universitaire de médecine généraleal les
moyens dont elle a besoin je pense par
exemple à la création de postes
d'enseignant des créations ne reposant
pas comme c'est trop souvent le cas sur
des postes vacants dans d'autres
spécialités les universités savent trop
combien en règle générale un poste
vacant est un poste perdu il n'est pas
non plus acceptable que la seule
alternative consiste à supprimer un
poste d'enseignant dans une filière pour
l'affecter à la filière universitaire de
médecine cette logique comptable ne
constitue pas une réponse durable aux
enjeux de formation des futurs médecins
de premier recours mais il faut
également que le processus de formation
des étudiants prennent en
compte Pr en compte la spécificité
propre à cette discipline c'est-à-dire
son caractère ambulatoire il faut par
exemple permettre la réalisation
effective en cabinet médical du stage
prévu au second cycle afin de
sensibiliser les étudiants à ce mode
d'exercice en leur permettant de
découvrir un autre modèle que celui
hospitalo universitaire aujourd'hui
encore très majoritaire alors que
certains proposent de réduire la durée
des études formant les médecins
généralistes nous considérons pour notre
part qu'il faudrait au contraire
pérenniser la 4e année de spécialisation
comme c'est le cas pour les autres
spécialités celle-ci pourrait
principalement être orienté vers la
réalisation de stages de longue durée
pouvant aller de 6 mois à un an et dans
des territoires qui souffrent d'une
sousdensification cela permettrait
d'assurer de manière continue une
présence pardon une présence médicale
conjointe à celle du médecin maître de
stage soulageant ce dernier dans ses
amplitudes de travail et facilitant
l'accès aux soins des patients cela
suppose naturellement un accompagnement
financier permettant de lever les
obstacles liés à l'accueil d'un
stagiaire en cabinet la présence d'un
interne nécessite de la part du maître
de stage un investissement en énergie et
en temps qui rallonge la consultation et
réduit d'autant le nombre de patients
qu'il peut accueillir dans la journée
cela peut avoir des conséquences
financières substantielles dans le cadre
d'une rémunération à l'acte et les
compensations financières actuellement
consenties semblent insuffisante pour
palier les pertes réelles enfin comme le
préconise le rabord Hulbert il apparaît
impératif de tenir compte des envies
mêmes des médecins et des étudiants
concernant les modes d'exercice de leur
profession toutes les enquêtes menées
auprès des professionnels l' testent les
médecins principalement les jeunes
diplômés veulent rompre avec l'isolement
qui est le leur ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à redouter une installation
syony de solitude et d'amplitude horaire
trop importante cela implique de
favoriser l'exercice regroupé et
principalement l'exercice
pluridisciplinaire notamment au sein de
maison de santé chacun s'accorde à
reconnaître que la
pluridisciplinarité constitue un
avantage certain tant pour les
professionnels que pour les patients qui
disposent ainsi dans un même lieu de
l'ensemble des prestations dont ils
peuvent avoir besoin or ce mode
d'exercice qui suppose un projet de soin
Inuit des temps de travail et de
concertation qui ne sont pas des temps
de soins et par conséquent ne donnent
pas lieu dans le cas d'un paiement à
l'acte à une rémunération il faut donc
impérativement développer comme nous
l'avions proposé dans le cadre de
l'examen par le Sénat de la loi
HPST une rémunération forfaitaire
celle-ci pourrait notamment inclure la
compensation du temps de travail
spécifique issu des besoins liés à
l'exercice regroupé la prise en charge
des temps dédiés à l'éducation
thérapeutique ou aux missions de
prévention
si nous sommes favorables à ces
expérimentations nous l'associons à une
condition primordiale le respect par ces
professionnels des tarifs opposable nous
ne pouvons concevoir que des fonds
publics puissent être destinés à des
professionnels de santé dont la pratique
tarifaire aurait pour effet de
participer à leur manière à
l'accroissement des renoncements aux
soins pour des motifs financiers enfin
pour conclure je voudrais aborder la
question des centres de santé municipaux
mutualistes ou associé
qui constitue le mode le plus ancien et
le plus répandu de l'exercice collectif
et puridisciplinaire de la médecine à
l'image du rapport valencien le rapport
de Madame Hubert note l'importance des
centres de santé notamment parce qu'il
contribue à lutter à la fois contre la
désertification médicale et contre le
renoncement aux soins bien que celui-ci
reste principalement axé sur la médecine
libérale ce tropisme est regrettable car
de plus en plus de jeunes diplômés
s'orientent vers un exercice salarié
qu'ils estiment plus en adéquation avec
le avec leur conception de la médecine
mais aussi avec leur mode de vie de la
même manière nous regrettons à l'image
de la Fédération nationale des centres
de santé que ce rapport limite les
centres de santé à une réponse sanitaire
d'exception qu'il serait bon de
développer uniquement en cas de
défaillance de l'organisation libérale
cette conception particulièrement
anachronique à nos yeux ne tire aucune
conclusion des réussites réalisées
quotidiennement par ces centres et qui
permettent une approche globale des
patients avec la pratique du tiers
payant la prévention l'duc l'éducation
en santé ou encore la
pluridisciplinarité aussi nous
considérons que ce mode d'exercice ne
doit pas être ne doit pas être écarté
des autres modes collectif d'exercice et
nous souhaitons que le gouvernement
s'engage à étendre au centre de santé
les financements qu'il entend développer
pour favoriser l'exercice collectif
libéral je vous
remercie je vous remercie mon chers
collègue dans la suite du débat la
parole est à Monsieur Pierre
colamba vous avez la parole chers
collègues
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues notutre système de santé
présentaient jusqu'à récemment tous les
avantages liberté individuelle d'accès
aux soins quasi universel pour le
patient universalité de la couverture
avec la CMU faible coût pour les
intéressés de leurs études et de leurs
formation liberté de prescription
d'installation de mode d'exercice pour
le médecin
qualité des soins
reconnus pour
résumer socialisation quasi intégrale du
coût des choix individuel qu'il s'agisse
du médecin comme du
patient côté médecin le système lui
assure globalement un bon niveau de
revenu un niveau progressant plus vite
que le salaire
moyen aucune contrepartie sociale autre
que celle qu'il s'impose à lui-même ne
lui est demandé pas même depuis 2003
d'assurer des gardes
le nerf du système c'est la rémunération
pour toutes parti à l'acte de 67 % des
des omnipraticiens
50 % des spécialistes dont 69 % des
radiologues et 65 % des cardiologues
mode de rémunération désormais appliqué
globalement à l'hôpital public dont les
ressources dépendent du nombre et de la
qualité des actes qui s'y pratiquent un
système libéral financé par l'argent
public impossible de rêver mieux sauf
qu'il s'est mis à
dysfonctionner en terme de coût en terme
qualitatif fil d'attente qui s'allonge
pour l'accès à certaines spécialités
surchauff des urgences qui ici ou là
ponctuellement prennent des allures de
cours des miracles extrême disparité de
la démographie médicale notre sujet de
cet après-midi le diagnostic est connu
la présence médicale est très variable
d'une région à l'autre entre les
départements d'une même région entre les
villes et les zones rurales entre les
quartier des villes et même entre les
secteurs ruraux d'un même département
encore plus variable s'agissant des
spécialistes entre provencealcô d'Azur
et la Picardie la densité des
spécialistes varie du simple au double
vous auriez de nombreux de nombreux
exemples à apporter même une démographie
médicale favorable comme dans mon
département leevin ne signifie
absolument pas pour autant que dans les
zones rurales la permanence des soins
est assurée je fais l'exemple dans un
canton de 5000 habitants 7 médecins euh
ce qui me paraît quand même relativement
suffisant aller chercher un médecin
disponible après les heures de bureau
vous avez un petit peu de problème on
avance le le chiffre de 2600000
personnes qui rencontrerait des
difficultés pour accéder à un
généraliste un spécialiste un
professionnel de santé en général et
ceci en dépit du fait a été souligner
qu'il y a il n'y a jamais eu autant de
médecins en France notamment de médecins
libéraux et de spécialistes que notre
densité médicale est tout à fait
comparable voire légèrement au-dessus de
celle de nos voisins des 15 en dépit du
fait aussi que le nombre d'actes n'a pas
cessé d'augmenter surtout dans la
spécialité le constat s'impose donc même
si dans les 10 ans qui viennent la
question des effectifs viendra encore
compliquer la donne ce n'est pas le
manque de médecins et de professionnels
de santé qui est responsable des déserts
médicaux mais le système pourquoi en
effet voulez-vous que des diplômés
essentiellement d'origine urbaine et
aisé formé à une médecine de plus en
plus technique a gagné leur vie en zone
rurale accepte des contraintes horaires
s'ils peuvent faire autrement puisqu'ils
n'ont aucune obligation pourquoi
voulez-vous qu'il s'en impose lors d'une
précédente discussion dans cette
assemblée j'avais présenté le dilemme à
Madame Bachelot et je dois dire à ma
surprise qu'elle ce qu'elle m'a répondu
donc m'a surpris je la cite j'indiquerai
pour faire écho au débat engagé par
Monsieur Colomba que nous ne pourrons
pas faire sur ce sujet l'économie d'une
réflexion philosophique quand la
puissance publique c'est-à-dire le
contribuable local le contribuable
national
ou le cotisant à la sécurité sociale
aura financé à grand renfort de
subvention des maisons médicales de
gardes ou des centres de santé
participer au fonctionnement de ces
installations régler les cotisations
sociales des médecins augmenter les les
rémunération comme nous le faisons déjà
avec une progression de plus de 20 %
dans certains secteurs rémunérer la
permanence des soins en plus des
consultations et des visites majorées
150 € la nuit payer for forfaitairement
la prise en charge des malades
chroniques pourrons-nous toujours arguer
qu'il s'agit de médecine libérale c'est
Madame Bachelot qui parle les jeunes
médecins pourront-ils toujours
revendiquer la liberté d'installation
certains médecins refusent d'assurer les
tâches les plus contraignantes comme les
garde de nuit puisque le système repose
sur le volontariat j'indique aussi qu'un
principe irréfragable veut que qui P
commande certaines exigences présentées
benoitement ici ou là sur toutes les
travé comme des mesures techniques
impliquent Infiné un changement de
système et l'instauration d'un service
public étatisé ou
paraétatisé il faut avoir le courage de
dire les choses j'ajouteraiis de le dire
et d'en tirer les conséquences parce que
on en est resté là toute mesure curative
un peu sérieuse étant actuellement
politiquement impossible on se limitera
donc à quelques granules homéopathiques
ce que fait très bien d'ailleurs le
rapport de Madame Hubert ce celle de ces
proposition que je préfère c'est
maintenir en activité des médecins
au-delà de 60 ans les pauvres faire
appel à des médecins retraités et je
cite inciter les internes à effectuer
une année supplémentaire de mission de
service public mais chers collègue
madame la ministre finalement puisque
nous sommes dans des déserts pourquoi ne
pas faire appel aux ONG l'é voocation je
pense ne manquerait
pas je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Tropéano s'il vous
plaît
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues longtemps venté
comme l'un des meilleurs du monde notre
système de santé présente aujourd'hui de
retoutables symptômes engorgement des
hôpitaux inégalité sociale dans l'accès
au soig et inégalité territoriale et ce
sujet a déjà été évoqué ce matin lors du
débat concernant la
ruralité les avancées scientifiques et
technologiques ont cert rendu la
médecine plus fiable mais les problèmes
d'organisation des soins et de
démographie médicale privent un grand
nombre de Français du bénéfice de ces
performances derrière la crise
budgétaire bien réelle est apparu la
fracture sanitaire dans certains
territoires en particulier ruraux la
permanence des soins est approximative
les délées d'accès en cas d'urgence sont
incompatibles avec l'efficacité des
soins les files d' chez les spécialistes
s'allogent en bref le désert médical
s'installe et gagne du terrain dans nos
campagnes les origines de ce problème
sont évidemment diverses ce n'est pasant
pour l'heure le nombre de médecins qui
est en cause d'après le dernier Atlace
du Conseil national de l'Ordre celui-ci
est en effet stabilisé à un niveau élevé
mais la répartition sur le territoire
l'île-de France compte 222 spécialistes
pour 100000 habitants soit le double de
la pque Cardie qui n'est pourtant pas à
proprement parler une zone rurale
reculée le manque d'attractivité de
certains territoires il est évidemment
pour beaucoup dans ces inégalités il est
clair qu'on ne fera jamais venir un
jeune médecin avec son conjoint dans une
commune où il n'y a pas une offre de
service de qualité ou un accès au
numérique de nouvelles générations les
conditions brutales et souvent
anarchique dans lesqueles sont conduites
depuis quelques années les
restructurations hpitalière ont
également un impact fort elles
démotivent les professionnels et
désorganisent la coordination des soins
enfin la la désaffection pour la
médecine généraliste et l'exercice
libéral il est aussi pour quelque chose
la carrière de médecin fait certes
encore rêver des générations de jeunes
gens qui voient non seulement une
manière de gagner leur vie mais aussi
une forme d'engagement d'altérité et
d'humanisme en revanche à la différence
de leurs aînés les jeunes diplômés
rejettent le schéma traditionnel du
médecin à tout faire isolé dans son
cabinet corps véable jour et nuit parmi
les nouveaux inscrits à l'ordre au 1er
janvier 2010 moins d'un sur 10 exerce en
cabinet 2 ti3 optent pour une activité
salariée et un/4 pour des remplacements
ce faible attrait pour l'exercice
libéral se vérifie même en radiologie
discipline pourtant poinée du doigt
souvent comme une des plus lucratives
contrairement aux idées reçues ce n'est
pas le niveau insuffisant de la
rémunération qui prime dans le refus de
l'installation mais surtout la charge
administrative trop lourde la solitude
de l'exercice ou encore les contraintes
de garde face à cette évolution
préoccupante qui n'est pas dire on ne
peut plus se contenter de mesures
isolées on ne peut plus se contenter de
promesses de telles inégalités entre
entre les territoires ne sont pas
admissibles dans notre République ce ne
sont pas les incitations fiscales et
sociales en zone de revitalisation
rurale la réforme de la première année
des études de médecine qui a été engagé
cette année ni les quelques mesures de
la loi HPST dont certains étaient au
demeurant positive comme la
régionalisation du numérosclusus la
reconnaissance de la médecine premier
secours ou le contrat d'engagement de
services publics qui vont régler le
problème durablement on le sait la
pénurie de médecin va s'aggraver avec le
vieillissement de la population médicale
actuellement dans mon département celui
de l'héros 60 % de médecins ont plus de
60 an nous devons donc aller plus loin
la qualité le nombre la formation la
répartition les types de pratique les
modes et niveau de rémunération des
hommes de l'art médical sont sans doute
à repenser à la lumière des besoins
médicaux notre collègue verra a évoqué
dans son intervention le rapport
d'Élisabeth Hubert sur la médecine de
proximité rapport qui a été remis en
novembre au président de la République
qui propose un ensemble de mesures appui
à l'exercice regroupé refonte totale les
tarifs de consultation rémunération
spécifique et incitative pour l'exercice
en zone Soudans développement également
de la télémédecine certaines sont
intéressantes le regroupement de
médecins et autres professionnels
médicaux ou paramédicaux en un même lieu
par exemple dans les maisons de santé
est une solution en milieu rural et
répond au besoins de partager
l'expérience le gouvernement s'est
engagé sur un objectif de 250 maisons de
santé
pluridisciplinaire je m'en réjouis mais
comme je l'ai déjà dit le succès de
cette démarche est lié à la présence sur
les territoires concernés d'un minimum
de service pour répondre aux besoins
légitimes des professionnels de santé et
de leur famille or à cet égard le
désengagement de l'État constitue le
maillon faible du dispositif quoi qu'il
en soit il est plus que temps de décider
et d'agir d'autant qu'en matière de
santé plus encore que dans d'autres
domaines de l'action publique les fruits
se récoltent à moyen et long terme reste
la question essentielle de savoir si les
jeunes pratriciens pourraient être un
jour contraint à une forme ou un lieu
d'exercice en fonction des besoins sans
être adepte de la coerition nous sommes
nombreux à douter de l'efficacité des
simples
incitations pouvez nous dire pouvez-vous
nous dire combien de contrats
d'engagement de servicees public ont été
signés depuis la loi
HPST je me demande d'ailleurs si ce
contrat n'est pas en réalité une fausse
bonne idée c'est finalement aux
étudiants les plus modestes qu'on
demandera d'aller exercer en zone rurale
car à n'en pas dououté les plus aisés
n'auront pas besoin d'obtenir une bourse
quant au contrat santé solidarité il
apparaît là encore comme un leure
comment croire qu'il permettra de lutter
contre les déserts médicaux quand on
imagine les difficultés de mise en œuvre
et la faiblesse des pénalités on entend
dire d'ailleurs que vous pourriez
revenir madame la ministre sur cette
disposition qu'en est-il exactement et
puis on peut se poser la question de
savoir comment nous pourrions redonner
le
goût aux étudiants du métier de
généraliste pour les étudiants donc en
médecine cette question devient épineuse
et urgente tant pour le corps médical
que pour les pouvoirs publics mais
également pour nos concitoyens qui
souvent nous demandent et sont inquiets
quant à la désertification médicale
notamment dans le milieu rural et il ils
sont crétifs de savoir qu'ils risquent
de ne pas pouvoir être soignés
lorsqu'ils seront
malades
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à madame la Présidente
borvoc s'il vous
plaît merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre chers
collègues à l'occasion enfin beaucoup
est déjà dit fait un peu de répétition
mais je voudrais dire quand même qu'à
l'occasion de la loi Hôpital Patient
Santé territoire le gouvernement hélas a
prouvé qu'en matière d'égale accès aux
soins il n'avait pas de solution bien
nouvelle à proposer quelques mois après
le rapport Huber pointe les graves
problèmes des déserts médicaux que tout
le monde avait souligné déjà à l'époque
mais les solutions ne sont pas
convaincantes en tout cas elles ne
convainquent pas si je j'en crois les
intervenants
l'opposition alors que n'a-t-on entendu
effectivement au moment de la loi
Hôpital Patient euh de du côté de la
majorité
euh lorsque des mesures contraignantes
étaient proposées pour inciter
contraindre donc on va dire puis
qu'elles étaient contraignantes euh des
professionnels de santé à installé là où
les manque était
patant je me souviens de Monsieur Vassel
bien placé pour parler de ces questions
sans ironie qui est allé jusqu'à
affirmer que la remise en cause du
principe de liberté d'installation des
médecins généralistes était
inconstitutionnel évidemment ce n'est
pas le cas et jusqu'où aller pour
essayer de convaincre de toute
évidence le principe de la liberté
d'installation était encore un tabou
pour la majorité parle aire mais je dois
le dire pas de façon
unanime alors donc et pour ceux qui
aiment les comparaison et c'est vrai
dans toute la majorité regardons ce qui
se passe en Allemagne que je sache pas
soviétique l'Allemagne est revenue sur
le principe dans les années 90 et
aujourd'hui les Allemands tout en étant
je crois pas moins bien soigner que les
Français ont réussi à résorber une
partie de leurs déserts médicaux pendant
ce temps les nôtres se développe le
phénomène en effet comme cela a été dit
par mes prédécesseurs n'est plus
cantonné dans les territoires faiblement
peuplé il gagne aussi les villes et les
régions où la démographie pourtant est à
au rendez-vous saanie et premier en
matière de démographie ainsi que
d'autres départements
urbains alors le gouvernement après
avoir fait mine d'agir donc de façon peu
convaincante et avoir fait voter en 2009
deux dispositions par le Parlement la
première faisant obligation pour les
médecins de déclarer leur congés et la
seconde mettant en œuvre des contrats
santé solidarité votre prédécessrice
madame la ministre s'est empressé à la
fin de l'année 2010 de prendre la
décision de sursoir à la publication de
leur décret d'application et euh donc
semble-t-il on est revenu à la case
desparts Ne rien faire la première
disposition à préciser Madame Bachelot
était en définitive trop discriminante
et pêché parce qu'elle indisposait le
corps médical sans doute gageons que
concernant la seconde la ministre
peut-être a finini par se rallier à nos
arguments qui disait qu'elle était
absolument inutile car rigoureusement
inapplicable comment en effet imaginer
sérieusement de demander à des médecins
installés en zone surdans on va dire de
se rendre ponctuellement en zone
sousdotée pour y faire des consultations
et assurer de façon pérenne accès aux
soins c'est assez surréaliste alors
aujourd'hui peut-être plus qu'il y a 2
ans nous pourrons vous convaincre mes
chers collègues ainsi que le
gouvernement qu'il existe des solutions
à cette situation grave et euh
susceptible de s'aggravé contenu de la
pyramide des âges comme cela a été dit
dans les années qui viennent tout
d'abord plutôt que de tenter en 20ain et
à tout prix d'attirer les médecins dans
les zones sous-dotées il est possible de
considérer le problème sous un autre
angle et de chercher à dissuader les
omnipatriciens praticiens pardon de
s'installer dans les zones surdotées
pour se faire on peut envisager de
soumettre l'installation des médecins à
l'autorisation des agences régionales de
santé on peut aussi décider de refuser
de façon temporaire le conventionnement
des médecins de premier recours qui
veulent exercer dans des zones où
l'offre de soins est déjà plus que
satisfaite écoutez à Paris on est
surdoté ça c'est la démographie médicale
mais 2 tiers des médecins spécialistes
sont en secteur 2 alors là rien à dire
et 50 % des généralistes sont aussi en
secteur 2 et là rien ne trouve personne
ne trouve à redire en tout cas parmi
vous or qu'est-ce qui se passe si la
population parisienne aisée ne se plaint
pas elle trouve que ça va très très bien
les plus modestes je vous le dis font de
plus en plus la queue aux urgences des
hôpitaux voilà la réalité alors
excusez-moi mais sur la liberté
d'installation il y a beaucoup à dire
quand la sécurité sociale finance les la
médecine bien en outre si l'on veut
essayer de régler un problème différent
mais connexe car lui lui aussi aggrave
les difficultés d'accéder aux soins on
peut également décider de retirer le
conventionnement de ceux qui bien que
diplômés de la spécialité de médecine
générale ne pratiqu pas effectivement
cette médecine de premier recours
certains s'installent ainsi en tant
qu'acupuncteur ou encore
en en
géologie il nous semble que cette
piste évidemment qui doit s'ajouter au
rehaussement du numérus closus
permettrait de donner une réponse
concrète plus concrète à la pénurie D'ni
praticienne dans certains territoirees
ensuite il est envisageable notre
collègue Maé l'a fait d'instituer une
sorte d'obligation pour les jeunes M de
s'installer pour une durée déterminée là
où ils sont particulièrement utiles
l'Académie de médecine évoquait déjà
cette possibilité en 2007 on peut pas
l'accuser d'être contre la médecine dans
la mesure où la formation de chaque
médecin représente pour la société une
charge financière de l'ordre de 200000 €
il ne paraît pas incongru de leur
demander comme dans certaines grandes
écoles d'accepter de mettre quelques
années de leur vie professionnelle au
service de la nation pour ma part
j'ajouterai qu'il se verait peut-être
intéressant
euh
de en plus de favoriser l'accès aux
études médicales de jeunes de catégorie
sociale modeste ce qui en général est
difficile par un système de prise en
charge postbac ave en contrepartie
l'obligation de service de dans tel dans
leur département par exemple ou dans des
département sous-dotés pendant un
certain nombre d'années pour conclure il
nous semble aussi particulièrement
nécessaire de fixer des règles
d'accessibilité des soins de premier
recours de telle sorte que la politique
régionale de santé contribue
effectivement à réduire les inégalités
en la matière tout d'abord le temps
d'accès à un professionnel de santé doit
se mesurer en terme de distance et de
durée dans un rapport sénatorial de 2008
il était préconisé un temps de trajet
d'une durée maximale de 30 minutes ça
paraît quand même suffisant en outre
l'accessibilité aux soins doit prendre
en compte le temps d' attente il faut
pouvoir consulter son médecin dans un
délai raisonnable enfin et cet aspect
nous somble de la plus grande importance
il faut que l'accès au tarifs opposa
c'est-à-dire non soumis à dépassement
d'honoraire devienne un critère
essentiel dans l'appréciation de
l'accessibilité aux soins de premier
recours donc nous attendons de vous mes
chers collègues que vous fassiez des
propositions concrètes et opérationnel
et nous demandons madame la ministre de
faire preuve d'ouverture et de
pragmatisme car il est urgent d'agir
merci je vous remercie je vous remercie
madame la Présidente la parole est à
Monsieur Jacques Blanc s'il vous
plaît bonjour monsieur le Président
Madame le ministre mes chers collègues
d'abord je me réjouis que le groupe
communiste a souhaité l'ouverture de ce
débat je dois dire d'ailleurs que quand
on regarde l'ordre du jour de cette
première semaine de travail du Sénat
politique agricole commune ce matin euh
ruralité et on a parlé des problèmes
médicaux et aujourd'hui ce soir des
certifications ça prouve qu'on est
préoccupé par la vie dans cet espace
rural et par ce qu'on peut apporter aux
populations le Sénat d'ailleurs s'est
très mobilisé et a la chance d'avoir un
éminent de nos collègues sénateur
Fourcade chargé de l'évaluation au bout
des 2 ans de la loi que nous avons vé et
il a déjà commencé un travail très
important donc le débat vient à son
heure et Madame le Ministre il vient à
un moment où il est important en effet
qu'on rappelle des choses puisque vous
venez de prendre cette responsabilité au
côté du ministre Bertrand monsieur
bertrin doit se rappeler que lorsqu'il
était au côté de dou blasie il y a un
rapport qui avait déjà été fait c'est le
rapport du professeur Yvon Berlan qui
avait d'ailleurs alerté
sur le besoin les risques par rapport à
la couverture médicale dans ces
conclusions il parlait un de
l'augmentation progressive et raisonnée
du numérus closus alors je sais bien que
c'est un sujet qui fâche et je demande
pour ma part une vraie révolution
culturelle je vous demande
d'échapper à ces influences théoriques
de gens qui comparent des chiffres alors
que ce n'est pas du tout la même
situation il y en a assez qu'on nous
explique qu'il y a trop de médecins qui
seraiitformés ou ou qu'on en manquerait
pas Madame le Ministre il faut que vous
sachiez quand on compare le nombre des
médecins formé qu'il faut quand même
tenir compte je vais vous donner un
exemple dans un département comme le
mien en Laer dans le centre d'urgence à
l'hôpital de mande pour assurer ces
urgences il faut 19 médecins quel est
l'autre pays au monde où dans une
situation équivalente de population et
cetera il faut 19 médecins pourquoi il
en faut 19 c'est pas eux qui sont à
cause il en faut 19 35 he
asreinte et nous sommes en face d' unee
situation où quand on regarde il y a pas
mal de médecins mais il en manque pour
assurer la réponse aux besoins quel est
l'élu ici qui n'a pas vécu une situation
à l'hôpital public dans une que
mutualiste ou privé ou dans la
couverture de profession libérale où ils
sont pas obligés d'aller g rien contre
l'appel à des médecins étrangers mais on
on prive ces pays de qualité de ces
médecins et donc surtout ne tombez pas
dans le piège de toute l'administration
qui va vous expliquer qui assez on en
forassé ce n'est pas vrai le numérus
closusus bien sûr était une nécessité on
l'a mal appliqué les gouvernements de
droite ou de gauche et on ne forme pas
assez de médecins on voit bien dans
toutes nos campagnes des jeunes qui ont
été éliminés dans un concours qui ne
répond d'ailleurs à aucun critère
humaniste de médecin hein et qui aurait
fait d'excellent médecin donc arrêtons
de dire qu'il en a assez premier point
c'était d'ailleurs dit déjà des
solutions d'incitation pour
l'installation de médecin dans les zones
alors c'est là où nous avons une
divergence moi je crois qu'il faut faire
confiance
aux acteurs et je suis contre les
contraintes et je suis pour le respect
de la liberté d'installation par contre
par contre je suis pour qu'il a des
mesures d'incitation vraie alors mais si
mon cher collègue je vais vous inviter à
venir en lozer on a pris le département
de la lozer a mis en place et je peux
vous montrer ici le guide d'installation
il y a
udiant internes qui ont signé il y en a
déjà un qui viit s'installer à Florac
seulement ça prend du temps mais c'est
vrai que les contrats qui peuvent être
établis avec l'engagement d'exercer
minimum 5 ans et quand ils sont là
depuis 5 ans ils restent c'est une
mesure d'incitation tout à fait forte
seulement ça prend du temps de même que
les contrats d'engagement que qui on été
mis en place dans la loi mais il y a que
2 ans et donc ça peut pas porter ses
fruits ça devrait permettre
l'installation de médecins dans ces
zones rurales ou d'ailleurs la la
qualité de vie aujourd'hui fera j'en
suis convaincu que demain ceux qui
auront découvert il faut troème
incitation par les stages il faut
héberger il faut
payer on le fait et rembourser les frais
de déplacement pour aller suivre des
cours à l'université ce sont donc des
mesures incitatives on en parlait on en
a mis en œuvre dans le cadre de la loi
sur l'hospitalisation avec Madame
machelot il y a des mesures aussi
d'incitation financière qui ont été
prise en compte dans le cadre de la loi
rurale les exonérations de charges avec
les zones de revitalisation rurale il y
a un certain nombre de mesures qui n'ont
pas encore fait la preuve de leur
efficacité mais c'est la
conjugaison écoutez quand je regarde moi
ce qui s'est passé en Angleterre quand
je regarde ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis je dis c'est bien la réponse
française le modèle français qui est le
meilleur la pénurie partout excusez-moi
et ici on peut sauver on peut sauver la
qualité il faut former davantage inciter
aux installations dans les zones rurales
qui en manquent par ces mesures par un
acte volontaire parce que il y a rien de
pire que les gens qui sont obligés
d'aller à tel ou tel endroit on mérite
mieux dans cet espace rural donc ce sont
des mesures incitatives et je demande à
notre collègue Jean-Pierre Fourcade de
mesurer comment ça va se développer ne
disons pas que ça marche pas alors
qu'elles sont mises en œuvre il y a 2
ans dans la loi d'hospitalisation ou la
loi de sur les territoires ruraux donc
je vous
demande Madame le Ministre libéré d' à
priori avec les rapports qui VI qui le
rapport uber qui vient compléter ce qui
avait été euh étudié avant avec un peu
de recul par rapport à la loi
hospitalisation je vous demande un de
faire sauter ces blocages de numerus
closus 2 ces 400 contrats qui ont été
d'engagement de l'État dont 200 pour les
internes 200 avant je crois qu'il faut
augmenter ce nombre avec des engagements
concrets de s'installer j'avais déposé
un amendement euh madame Madame Bachelot
avait dit c'est intéressant mais on
verra dans un décret pour favoriser
aussi le remplacement dans les zones
vous le
savez les médecins mettent 10 ans
aujourd'hui font des remplacements mant
10 ans et bien si on favorise laavenue
de ces remplaçants dans les zones en
risque de désertification on les fixera
et ils pourront rester et s'installer
donc pas de remise en cause de ce p
fondamental de liberté hors duquel il y
a eu des échecs partout vous allez pas
me dire qu'il y a eu des résultats
spectaculaires et positifs de la qualité
de ce qui est apporté tirons les leçons
de la situation qui se dégrade à cause
du manque de médecin à cause de de
l'absence jusqu'à présent de mesures
incitative et je suis convaincu 3è point
que la mise en place des maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire sont une c'est c'est
une excellente réponse moi j'ai exercé
la médecine dans un espace rural oh
combien isolé en lososire je sais ce que
c'est que de me lever la nuit d'aller
voir des malades tout seul travailler 24
he c'est fini il faut donc qu'on
permettre à ces médecins tout en gardant
le choix de leur exercice libéral de
travailler dans des maisons
pluridisciplinaires je puis vous dire
que dans ma modeste commune de la
canourg j'en crée une qui sera ouverte à
la fin de cette année qui nous
permettra d'être
attractif pour que on avait quatre
médecins il y en a deux qui prennent la
retraite les deux autres peuvent paser
seuls ils ont besoin de travailler
ensemble avec aussi les infirmières
parce que là aussi on ninforme pas assez
les kinés les autres professions
paramédicales je crois que la maison
médicale pluridisciplinaire est une
bonne réponse qui respecte les réistes
libéral mais qui permet de faire tomber
des blocages parce que c'est vrai qu'en
plus et je terminerai là-dessus on
l'oublie ce qui peut-être faéésiter le
plus le médecin de s'installer tout seul
en dehors des problèmes d'organisation
de vie c'est l'angoisse maises chers
collègues peut-être certains le savent
mais quand vous êtes seul en face d'un
malade où il y a un diagnostique à faire
un acte thérapeutique d'urgence à mettre
en œuvre
excusez-moi c'est terriblement
anxiogène et si vous êtes dans une
maison médicale pluridisciplinaire avec
l'infirmière vous pourrez discuter avec
d'autre médecin vous pourrez changer
vous pourrez même utiliser demain les
techniques nouvelles grâce au au au très
haut débit et cetera
donc ne cassons pas ce qui est la chance
même de la qualité de la distribution
des soins dans notre pays et je crois
que c'est l'exercice libéral associé
avec des systèmes hospitaliers et cetera
traitons les vrais problèmes le nombre
de médecins des mesures incitatives des
modèles et l'ouverture grâce aux maisons
pluridisciplinaires de maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaire de travail dans des
conditions qui permettront de libérer le
médecin de cette angoisse qui est
parfois terrible mais qui est tout à
l'honneur du corps médical n'oublions
pas cette réalité humaine n'allons pas
casser notre système mais au contraire
faisons confiance et allons de l'avant
alors madame le ministre vous avez une
grande
responsabilité ne tombez pas dans le
piège qui peut-être tendu parfois pour
des raisons idéologiques mais au
contraire restons fiers car mes chers
collègues écoutez quand on fait le tour
du monde on s'aperçoit quand même que
c'est encore en France qu'on est le
mieux
soigner merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Nathalie Goulet s'il
vous
plaît
bonjour ah après la losire après la
loosire ça va pas être très simple mais
enfin on est entre nous finalement euh
monsieur le Président Madame le ministre
mes chers collègues ce débat c'est un
peu comme le mur des lamentations
l'espoir en moins euh et je remercie et
d'emblé le groupe CRC sppg de l'avoir
initié parce que finalement il est
fondamental pour beaucoup d'entre nous
de PLFSS en PLFSS la situation ne
s'améliore pas du tout de débat en débat
la situation
empire et de rapport en rapport nous
sommes d'ailleurs à un anniversaire
pratiquement le 26 janvier 2006 Xavier
Bertrand présentait une communication au
Conseil des ministres pour essayer
d'endiguer les problèmes de démographie
médicale nous voilà 5 ans après alors
moi je repr présente l'or en Basse
Normandie alors que la moyenne nationale
est de 320 praticiens pour 100000
habitants
Lorne a une densité de 70 médecins pour
110 habitants 100000 habitants
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes
pratiquement lanterne rouge ou lanterne
noire mon collègue Hervé Moret est
encore un peu derrière nous mais mais
c'est grave c'est grave et il ne s'agit
pas de de choses théoriques il s'agit
d'une d'une d'un problème d'un problème
extrêmement pratique et les densités
médicales mentionnées n'expriment que
des moyennes la situation de certains
territoire est très dégradé quand elle
n'est pas à proprement parler totalement
alarmante les travaux conduits avec
l'ARS sur la médecine libérale met en
exerg des zones étendues en état de
sous-médicalisation il en est ainsi de
la totalité du département de l'ordne de
la moitié du département de la Manche et
d'un/art du département du du Calvados
basseenormandie région à laquelle
j'appartiens euh on ajoute à ça le le
départ en retraite des médecins cette
proportion dépassera 60 % dans le
département de l'Orne dans les 15 ans et
au regard des sorties annuelles du
cursus universitaire médical ces
prochaines années le solde demeurera
négatif on peut envisager que ce n'est
qu'en 2020 que le nombre d'entrées dans
la profession de médecin pourrait égaler
le nombre de sorties nous sommes là dans
le dans le concret Madame le Ministre et
pas dans l'incantation il faut également
souligner mais beaucoup d'autres l'ont
dit que les besoins de santé vont
évoluer du fait du vieillissement de la
population prendre en considération
évidemment les aspirations des nouveaux
praticiens là aussi on l'a dit quant aux
spécialité il faut plus de 6 mois dans
mon département pour avoir un
rendez-vous avec un oftalmo et je dois
pas être la seule dans ce pardon ah bah
oui bon alors venez dans l'Orne euh euh
alors à à ce stade je je revois mon
intervention parce que j'ai partagé mon
temps de parole avec Hervé Moret et donc
je vais être beaucoup plus courte mais
en même temps je voudrais profiter de
cette tribune pour rendre hommage aux
élus locaux parce que c'est deux que
sont venus les premières solutions et
pas du législateur les premières maisons
de la santé ont été créées dans les
années 90 dans mon département je ne
crois pas que ce soit une réponse
univoque je crois que c'est une réponse
parmi d'autres mais vous pouvez avoir
des maisons de la santé très bien
organisées et pas de médecin de d donc
le problème de la maison de la santé
c'est un élément qui peut fidéliser un
certain nombre de jeunes médecins ou les
aider à venir éventuellement sécuriser
je je je comprends ce que dit notre
collègue blanc ça peut les sécuriser
aussi d'être en groupe mais en même
temps ce n'est ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
la
solution je voudrais également rendre
hommage à Pierrejean lancr qui est notre
directeur régional de
l'ARS qui qui gère la pénurie avec Briot
et intelligence et qui essae de faire au
mieux avec les moyens du bord et je dois
dire que de ce point de vue-là il a un
dialogue avec les élus qui est tout à
fait essentiel et moi ce que je crois à
ce niveau du débat c'est qu'il faut
absolument trouver des solutions qui
soient pertinentes les solutions en loer
sont pas les les solutions en
Basse-Normandie elles sont pas non plus
même si le problème se pose dans les
mêmes termes dans les dans les
périphéries des grandes villes qui sont
sousdoté et je crois que le fait d'avoir
des ARS et le fait d'avoir des réponses
adaptées au territoire me semble être
vraiment la bonne solution ceci étant
chez nous le plan Hôpital 2012 a été un
vrai succès un vrai succès même si au
départ il a été un peu chahuté le
résultat est tout à fait est tout à fait
excellent et je voudrais à ce à ce stade
de des interventions vous dire qu'il
qu'il ne sera pas possible d'And cette
pénurie si nous n'avons pas de mesures
coercitives pour faire venir les
médecins en zone rurale et en zonees
sous équipé parce que personne ne
viendra tous les
PSLA initiés par les élus ne seront que
des que des procédés et des palliatifs
qui ne fonctionnera pas qui ne
fonctionnera pas si nous n'avons pas les
praticiens vous avez des équipements
cher vous avez des équipements lourds
parler de télémédecine ou parler de
médecine à distance quand vous n'avez
pas de ha débit quand les portables ne
fonctionnent pas quand vous avez des
zones blanches parce que c'est l'effet
Mathieux car à celui qui a tu donneras
il aura tout en abondance et à celui qui
n'a pas tu enlèveras même ce qui l'a
quand vous avez un territoire où vous
n'avez pas de haut débit où vous avez
des zone blanche où vous n'avez pas de
médecin ù vous n'avez pas de sapeur
pompier volontaire qu'est-ce qui se
passe tout le monde arrive à l'hôpital
duent notre collègue n'est pas là mais
c'est comme ça que ça finit par arriver
c'est comme ça que que les urgences sont
remplies de gens qui ne devrai pas y
aller donc je voudrais en conclure
conclure simplement et rapidement pour
laisser du temps Hervé Moret qui a des
choses à vous dire sûrement beaucoup
plus intéressantes que moi et en
conclusion madame le ministre je vous
diraiis que le bonheur est dans le prê à
condition d'être en bonne
santé je vous remercie ma cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Luc Fichet
s'il vous plat
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues en introduction
permettez-moi d'abord de profiter de
cette tribune pour dire un mot sur les
difficultés d'accès aux soins
l'inéquitable répartition des médecins
entre les région de France participe à
cette difficulté cela a été souligné
mais la précarité la pauvreté sont aussi
des facteurs de retard à se soigner
ainsi que le refus de certains
professionnels aujourd'hui de sculter
des patients de la
CMU que dire des nouvelles dispositions
sur l'aide médicale d'État imposer aux
malades sans papier et sans ressources
une contribution forfaitaire de 30 €.
c'est condamner les personnes concernées
à un retard de soins si ce n'est à pas
de soins du tout
c'est une atteinte à la dignité humaine
et c'est aussi une faute de santé
publique le gouvernement fait peu de
publicité au récents rapport de l'Igas
et de l'Inspection générale des finances
pour lesquels ce dispositif est
financièrement inadapté et est porteur
de risqu sanitaires il serait bon madame
la ministre que le gouvernement entende
les nombreuses voix qui demandent la
suspension de cette mesure inique et
discriminatoire le débat qui nous réunit
cet après-midi l'initiative de nos
collègues communistes républicains et
citoyens de nous permettre d'apporter
des solutions concrètes et immédiates à
la disparition lente et inéluctable de
la présence des professionnels médicaux
dans nos communes rurales mais aussi
dans certaines villes quel est le
constat il a été fait je je le reprends
rapidement les médecins qui sont
présents dans nos territoires
vieillissent la moyenne d'âge des
médecins en Finistère c'est
6 ans plus du tiers a dépassé les 60 ans
et il ne trouve bien évidemment pas de
professionnel pour leur succéder les
jeunes médecins cela a été dit aussi
nous disent qu'ils ne veulent plus être
corvéable à merci ils ne veulent plus
exercer de manière isolée ils
expérimentent ils expriment la volonté
de profiter de leurs enfants et d'avoir
des loisirs le conjoint ou la conjointe
veut exerter exercer sa profession et
les habitants quant à eux sont inquiets
de la disparition de leur médecin après
la fermeture de nombreuses maternités et
de certains hôpitaux de proximité nos
concitoyens voient les temps d'attente
pour consulter un spécialiste s'allonger
on a parlé tout à l'heure de 6 mois
pouralmour je disais que chez nous en
Bretagne on atteignait un an les
distances pour trouver un généraliste
sont de plus en plus importantes et du
coup les urgences sont encombrés par de
la
bobologie ainsi à morly dans une commune
de 18 habitants il faut aujourd'hui donc
un temps il y a plus de gynécologue et
poural mot je l'ai déjà dit quant aux
Mair aux élus ils sont les premiers
interlocuteurs à qui l' reproche ses
carences alors que je veux le rappeler
ici de façon
solennelle l'accès aux soins est une
prérogative de l'état des annonces sont
faites régulièrement par les pouvoirs
publics jurant la main sur le cœur que
cette situation sera prochainement rayée
tout récemment encore le président de la
République a semblé découvrir le
problème en effet dans un discours le
1er décembre à Orbec qui succédait à un
autre discours sur le même thème le 16
avril à Livri Gargan il a déclaré vous
n'aurez pas longtemps à attendre avant
de voir la détermination du gouvernement
en la matière nous attendons
toujours la loi Hôpital Patient Santé
territoire avait instauré le contrat
santé solidarité ce contrat semblait pas
à l'époque allit assez loin il avait le
mérite d'exister des solutions plus
radicales plus coercitives devaient être
trouvé j'avais déposé lors de la
discussion du projet de loi Hôpital
Patient Santé et territoire un
amendement dont le but était d'obliger
les nouveaux médecin à pratiquer un
minimum de 2 ans dans les zones
déficitaires en espérant qu'ils y
trouvent intérêt je n'ai pas été suivi
la majorité n'a rien trouvé de mieux que
de vider de sa substance contrat santé
solidarité dès l'été suivant l'adoption
de la loi HPST les quelques mesures
contraignante obligation de donner la
date de ces absences l'obligation de
soutien dans les zones déficitaires ont
été tout bonnement
annulé pourtant et les associations de
patients l'ont encore rappelé au mois de
décembre les déserts médicaux persiste
alors que l'assurance maladie verse une
prime de 25000 à 28000 € par an et par
médecin installés en zone
déficitaire comme le pointe le rapport
d'Élisabeth Hubert une despistes est de
bien définir ce qu'est un désert médical
elle renvoie cette définition au travail
des nouvelles agences régionales de
santé qui ont avec la loi HPS un rôle
important sur cette matière sur cette
question le gouvernement commeun son
habitude fait un pas en avant et trois
pas en arrière nous ne per avons aucun
projet construit aucun projet travaillé
qui permette de penser qu'il y ait une
réelle volonté de structurer une offre
de santé harmonieuse et efficace auprès
de tous les Français alors le remè de
miracle les maisons de santé don ce
Gasse nos gouvernant se développe à
l'initiative de nos collectivités qui
sansettete pour répondre à des
obligations qui ne sont pas les leurs
l'État participe mais faiblement au
financement
en effet les les maires des communes
rurales ou des communes pér urbaines que
le gouvernement tend trop souvent
astigmatiser que mauvais gestionnair
font face à la pénurie parce que il y a
urgence ils doivent séduire des
professionnels de santé dont le nombre
cela a été dit à plusieurs reprises est
en augmentation professionnels de santé
qui n'ont aucune
obligation aucune contrainte les mettre
autour d'une table les les invités à
rédiger un projet
médical et enfin les élus vont
construire une maison de santé mais le
tout sans aucune assurance de maintenir
une offre de santé pérenne sur leur
territoire ça veut dire que on peut
réunir des professionnels de santé
rédiger un projet médical construire des
maisons médicales et puis se retrouver
sans rien à la fin parce que entre-temps
bah ils auront pris d'autres décisions
d'autres orientations on n'ura tout
simplement pas trouvver les jeunes MC
que l'on
espérait aussi je le répète l' l'État
doit prendre sa pleine responsabilité
pour lutter contre la désertification
médicale dans sa convention sur
l'égalité réelle le Parti socialiste
propose la mise en place d'un bouclier
rural c'est ce vers quoi nous devons
tendre faire en sorte que les service
public essentiel ne soit pas à plus de
20 minutes de chaque citoyen et bien
évidemment le médecin généraliste en
fait partie mais les services d'urgence
ne doent pas être à plus de 30 minutes
et ceux d'une maternité à plus de 45
minutes plus qu'une politique de
réconciliation avec les médecins dont le
métier est difficile et essentiel c'est
ce pacte républicain aujourd'hui urgent
que nous devons engager avec nos
concitoyens pour un égal accès au soins
pour tous je vous
remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Laurent betteille s'il vous
plaît monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues au cours de
ces derniers mois le président de la
République a rappelé qu' après la
réforme de l'hôpital la priorité dans le
domaine de la santé c'est la médecine
libérale plusieurs déplacements ont été
l'occasion pour le chef de l'État de
faire des annonces en faveur des
médecins généralistes mais le problème
concerne d'ailleurs tout autant les
médecins
spécialistes débattre de la
désertification médicale c'est évoquer
entre autres des problèmes géographiques
sociologiques avec deux défis majeurs
qui doivent être relevés le premier sur
lequel Jacques Blanc s'est étendu tout à
l'heure consiste à enrayer la baisse du
nombre de médecins si en 2009 il y avait
290 médecins pour 100000 habitants nous
savons que la situation va se dégrader
jusqu'en 2020 date à laquelle la densité
de médecins aura retrouvé son niveau de
1980 ça suppose effectivement une
réaction forte d'autant que cette
réduction touche plus fortement
l'exercice libéral nous savons dans nos
départements et notamment dans les sones
chers collègues verra que les départs en
retraite non remplacés sont une
illustration dramatique de cette baisse
à cela s'ajoute évidemment la
répartition inégale des effectifs sur le
territoire ce phénomène ne concerne pas
que la France profonde mes chers
collègues il concerne également des
départements proches des grandes villes
comme les sones et je voudrais citer un
un se exemple mais nous avons dans le
sud de l'estonne toute une zone dans
laquelle il ne reste plus que 6 médecins
qui ont tous plus de 58 ans et d'ici
quelques années nous allons nous trouver
dans une
situation dramatique et par conséquent
le deuxième défi majeur est de rendre la
médecine libérale plus
attractif l'exercice libéral a perdu son
attractivité nous le savons raison abord
de l'évolution de l'hôpital qui offre le
salariat et qui permet et là aussi
Jacques Blanc l'a souligné avec raison
un travail en équipe qui est sécurisant
et également l'évolution des attentes
des médecins qui ne travaillent plus
comme autrefois qui aspirent à
travailler avec leurs confrères de
manière beaucoup plus flexible
aujourd'hui un médecin diplômé sur 10
seulement fait le choix de l'exercice
libéral ce chiffre doit retenir notre
attention même si le numéro rus closus
des étudiants en médecine a augmenté
insuffisamment je n'y reviens pas non
nombre d'entre eux deviennent
aujourd'hui des médecins conseil des
médecins du travail les femmes médecins
choisissent de préférence une voix qui
leur permet d'avoir plus de temps pour
leurs enfants et personne ne songerait à
le leur reprocher de plus les médecins
d'aujourd'hui font face il faut quand
même le dire à une bureaucrae
bureaucratisation croissante certains
estiment à 36 % le temps de travail qui
est consacré à des démarches
administratives en moyen en pour un
généraliste qui est considérable et pose
aussi
problème ils font face également à des
contrôles permanent de la sécurité
sociale des horaires à rallonge et juste
à juste titre un certain nombre de
médecins ne veulent plus assurer tout
seul des horaires de 8 à 22h dans des
endroits peu sûrs avec des cas lourds
qui prennent plus de temps et les
transforme souvent en assistant sociale
aujourd'hui le médecin de famille tel
qu'on le concevait autre fois n'existe
pratiquement
plus sur la base du rapport de Madame
ellisabeth Hubert ancienne ministre de
la Santé le 1emier décembre dernier le
président de la République a précisé son
projet de réforme la médecine de
proximité réforme de la rémunération des
généralistes libéraux l'étant l'idée
n'étant pas de revenir sur le paiement à
l'acte mais d'y ajouter des compléments
en fonction de ce qu'il convient
d'appeler des contraintes alors après un
un règlement pour le paiement à l'acte
le une deuxième part reviendrait à une
rémunération forfaitaire qui financerait
certaines activités comme les
permanences de garde dans des maisons
médicales ou les médecins qui
remplissent une fonction de service
public en s'installant dans des déserts
médicaux je crois sincèrement aux
maisons de santé notamment rural avec
généraliste infirmiers ma sœur et cetera
qui pourrait être un remède pour Pier à
cette désertification médicale avec un
potentiel de patients ou une amorce pour
attirer d'autres médecins généralistes
et également des
spécialistes un nouveau véhicule
juridique adapté à la diversité des
situations pour les pôles de santé
regroupés me semble également un
excellent
objectif nous avons dans les sones un
problème d'insuffisance
d'infirmier nous avons dans le sud de
les sonnes toute une zone où il n'y a a
pas de service d'infirmier à domicile et
chez nous aussi il faut aujourd'hui
attendre 6 mois pour obtenir un
rendez-vous avec un spécialiste que ce
soit ophtalmologiste gynécologue pour
citer que c'est quelques cas nous enend
n'atteignons pas le les records de la
Bretagne mais il n'empêche que même 6
mois c'est totalement insupportable tout
le monde en est conscient un troisème
niveau serait défini en fonction des
objectifs de santé publique leur respect
la création d'un guichet unique destiné
à faciliter la création de ces pôles de
santé avant le 1er juillet 2011 pour
tous les professionnels de santé qui
voudraient créer un pôle de santé avec
les élus me paraît une excellente
réponse à la demande forte de nos
départements ou de nos cantons où
persiste cette désertification médicale
à
l'énumération non exotif de ces mesures
et et de cette situation nous comptons
sur vous madame le secrétaire d'É état
pour répondre à cette situation qui est
préoccupante et pour laquelle nos
concitoyens attend de la part du
gouvernement une réaction qui soit à la
hauteur de cette situation je vous
remercie je remercie mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Hervé Moret il
va bénéficier d'une de quelques minutes
de supplément que lui a grignoté madame
Goulet vous avez la parole mon chers
collèg merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je voudrais d'abord
remercier le groupe CRC SPG d'avoir pris
l'initiative de ce débat remercier ma
collègue Nathalie Goulet d'avoir bien
voulu me laisser quelques minutes de son
temps et si j'ai souhaité ces quelques
minutes c'est non pas pour vous parler
du département de l'URE qui a le triste
privilège d'être dernier en matière de
démographie médicale mais pour vous dire
toute ma conviction madame la ministre
que nous ne réglerons pas le problème de
la démographie médicale en restant dans
l'incitatif je suis j'en suis navré en
désaccord profond avec mon collègue et
ami Jacques Blanc je ne suis pourtant
pas pour reprendre son expression un
idéologue de gauche mais je ne crois pas
du tout que l'incitatif marchera en cela
je partage l'avis du président de la
République qui en septembre 2008 disait
en matière de démographie médicale il
faut s'inspirer au minimum des N tion
entre l'assurance maladie et les
infirmières ces dernières ayant accepté
de ne pas s'installer dans les zones où
elles sont trop nombreuses je ne partage
pas en revanche l'avis du président de
la République qui il y a quelques
semaines le 29 novembre dernier disait
la coercition ça ne marche pas car ce
qui ne marche pas et on le voit c'est
les mesures purement incitatives ça
n'est pas moi qui le dit c'est un
certain nombre de rapports de personnes
beaucoup plus compétentes que moi il y a
eu le rapport de notre collègue Jul il y
a quelques années il y a eu le rapport
des députés Bernier député UMP et Paul
député socialiste et il y a eu le
rapport du ha conseil de l'assurance
maladie il y a eu le rapport du Conseil
de l'Ordre et ce sujet j'ai eu
l'occasion de l'évoquer lors du débat
sur la loi HPST en 2009 où j'avais
proposé deux amendements que je souhaite
rappeler aujourd'hui car je suis
convaincu qu'un jour on y viendra le
premier c'était de dire que lorsque des
médecins s'installent dans une zone
bénéficiant d'une offre de soins élevée
ils ne bénéficient pas du remboursement
de leurs honoraires selon le modèle qui
s'applique pour les
infirmières le deuxième amendement que
j'avais déposé c'était de prévoir que
les jeunes diplômés s'installent 3 ans
minimum dans une zone où l'offre de
soins est déficitaire et j'avais proposé
que ça ne s'applique qu'à partir de
2017 pour qu'on laisse le temps
éventuellement aux mesures incitatives
de faire leurs preuvees et si les
mesures incitatives avait fait leur
preuve et bien naturellement cet
amendement aurait pu tomber et ce qui
est très intéressant à propos de ces
amendements c'est que j'ai eu des
réactions d'une violence incroyable le
rapporteur n'hésitant pas à dire que je
voulais rétablir le STO
ou disant que je voulais forcer les
médecins à aller dans des trous c'est
pour vous dire la violence et l'aspect
caricatural du débat sur ce point et je
dois dire que c'est très intéressant de
de voir d'ailleurs qui avait voté ces
amendements parce que le groupe
amendement donc avait recueilli très peu
de voix mais j'avais souhaité les
maintenir et y compris obtenir un
scrutin public sur l'un d'entre eux le
groupe crcspg avait votter en totalité
ces amendements quelques RDSE et
quelques membres du groupe de l'Union
centriste avaient voté cet amendement
mais en revanche aucun sénateur UMP et
aucun sénateur socialiste n'avait voté
ces amendements qui étaient semble-t-il
politiquement incorrecte alors
aujourd'hui ma conviction elle est
intacte et je je suis convaincu que les
mesures incitatives ne marche pas je
donne rendez-vous à tous ceux qui le
souhaitent dans 5 ans dans 10 ans dans
15 ans et je suis vraiment navré que
Madame Bachelot a mis entre parenthèses
le dispositif contrat santé solidarité
qui était le seul élément un temps soit
peu contraignant très peu d'ailleurs
mais un temps soit peu contraignant de
la loi HPST qui je le dis aujourd'hui
avec beaucoup de de gravité de tristesse
n'aura aucun effet sur la démographie
médicale et je suis vaincu je l'ai dit
qu'un jour un gouvernement peut-être
plus courageux que les autres et
j'espère qu'il sera plutôt de droite que
de gauche mais peu importe l'espèce aura
le courage aura le courage de prendre
des mesures fortes en la matière et je
le dis je trouve qu'il n'y a rien de
choquant à demander à des jeunes
diplômés qui ont leurs études financées
par l'état de rendre un service à l'état
en allant là où on a besoin d'eux
pendant quelques années il y a quantité
de professions où ça existe déjà et ça
ne choque personne je ne vois pas pour
pourquoi il en irait différemment pour
les médecins alors pour conclure ce
matin nous avons eu un débat très
intéressant sur la ruralité et on est en
plein dans dans le sujet puisque Bruno
Le Maire en conclusion de ce débat a
considéré que le problème numéro 1
aujourd'hui de la ruralité c'était celui
de la démographie médicale et je partage
naturellement ce qu'il a dit et c'est
parce que je partage cet avis que
j'espère que le gouvernement ne jouera
pas indéfiniment l'autruche en se
voilant la face et en refusant de voir
les choses telles qu'elles et qu'un jour
il prendra les mesures courageuses qui
s'imposent il en va de la vitalité et
même de la vie tout court de nos
territoires ruraux je vous
remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur George
patient s'il vous
plaît
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers
collègues ce débat tombe à point nommé
puisqu'il me permet d'aborder le
problème criant du secteur de la santé
dans mon département la Guyane et je
tiens à remercier le groupe CRC qui est
à l'origine de cette
initiative ici il est question de
désertification médicale en Guyane
malheureusement nous avons dépassé ce
stade nous ne sommes pas dans un
processus de déficit ou d'exode de
médecin tout simplement parce que nous
sommes déjà un désert
médical le diagnostic est sévère
implacable d'autant plus que le
département est confronté à une
croissance démographique exceptionnelle
avec un taux de 3,9 % le plus important
de France l'un des plus importants au
monde et qu'il détient les indicateurs
de santé parmi les plus mauvais de
France France pour ne pas dire les plus
mauvais en effet la Guyane dispose d'une
espérance de vie inférieure de 4 ans à
celle de la
métropole 79 ans pour les femmes 72 ans
pour les hommes d'un taux de mortalité
infantile de 10,5 pour 1000 naissanceces
au lieu de 4 dans le reste de la France
des pathologies qui ont des prévalences
plus élevées que dans le reste de la
France diabète hypertension artérielle
sans oublier le VIH un taux important de
maladie anentérique surtout dans les
communes de l'intérieur de la Guyane
tels que typhoïd gastro-entérites
diarrée infectieuse entraînant des
retards de développement et scolaire
chez les enfants une situation sanitaire
plus que dégradée qui nécessiterait une
couverture sanitaire adaptée à des
besoins croissants et pourtant en
matière de démographie médicale force
est de remarquer que la Guyane souffre
toujours d'un déséquilibre important par
rapport à la à la métropole le
département est entièrement classé zone
déficitaire en médecins libéraux la
directrice de la caiss générale de
sécurité sociale de Guyane n'hésitant
pas à déclarer qu'il y a trois fois
moins de médecins dans ce département
que ceux dont il a
besoin la densité moyenne en médecin
généraliste médecin spécialiste
infirmier masseur kinésithérapeute et
dentiste est plus qu'alarmante on compte
pour 100000 habitants donné 2009 38
médecins généralistes en Guyane contre
112 en France métropolitaine
respectivement 83 et 82 en Martinique et
en Guadeloupe 22 médecins spécialistes
contre 88 en France métropolitaine
respectivement 48 et 60 en Martinique et
en Guadeloupe 38 chirurgiens dentiste
pardon contre 62 en France
métropolitaine encore faut-il préciser
que les médecins généralistes et
spécialistes ont pour 30 % d'entre eux
entre 55 et 70 ans et qu'ils sont
concentrés sur l'île de Cayenne et sur
courou beaucoup de communes ayant déjà
une densité inférieure à 3IS médecins
généralistes par tranche de 5000
habitants se retrouvent ainsi très
éloigné d'un service
d'urgence la saette d'alarme a été m
fois actionnée les propositions ne
manquent pas elles ont largement été
développé dans des rapports avis et
différents plans qu'ell soi local
national rapport de Madame uber remis le
23 novembre au président de la
République elles avancent les mêmes
mesures la Guyane doit être dotée d'une
véritable politique volontariste d' à
l'installation de médecins libéraux
certes il y a eu des avancées je pense
au tarif de la consultation je pense
aussi à l'installation de médecins
étrangers exception guyanaise en France
mais il est des demandes locales telles
que la zone franche médicale et la
réduction de l'roit de M pour le
matériel professionnel et technique afin
de faciliter l'investissement des
spécialistes qui sont restés lettres
mortes l'accent doit être égal également
mis sur la continuité territoriale qui
est à renforcer dans un territoire aussi
grand que le Portugal avec de très
fortes disparités territoriales et une
fracture entre la bande littorale assis
bien équipé et l'intérieur enclavé c'est
un point essentiel l'absence d'avion
sanitaires dédiés au d'hélicoptère pour
la sécurité civile autant que
l'isolement de certaines populations
pose un problème majeur en matière
d'égalité d'accès aux soins certaines
communes sont particulièrement démunies
en infrastructure les les d'intervention
sont extrêmement longs les systèmes de
communication en cas d'alerte restent
insuffisant je rappelle que le
dispositif d'aide au transport aérien et
la définition des critères doc 3
constitue l'un des objectifs du Plan
Santé autremère et qu'à ce jour aucune
initiative n'a été communiquée alors que
c'est un élément crucial au titre de la
continuité territoriale afin de réduire
les charges importantes de transport des
établissements d'autre part de réels
moyens financiers doivent être garantis
pour améliorer la couverture sanitaire
en équipement technologique de pointe il
est navrant de constater que dans le
plan Hôpital 2012 seul 2,2 % de
l'enveloppe globale sont consacrés aux
outremes autre mesure d'importance et
essentielle le renforcement de la
formation et son adaptation aux
spécificités du département à ce sujet
la demande d'augmentation du numéros
clausus pour les outr Mair n'a été que
partiellement entendu puisque pour la
rentrée universitaire
2010-2011 seulement trois places de plus
ont été prévues pour l'université des
Antilles Guyanes quant à la Faculté de
médecine des Antilles Guyanes créée en
elle ne dispose à l'heure actuelle que
de 23 personnels hospitalau
universitaires sans une accélération du
nombre de création de postes cette
faculté parviendra au niveau du CHU de
Limoge que dans 60 ans pourtant celui-ci
est le moins pourvu de France après le
CHU des anties Guyanes bien sûr pour
pour l'heure nous sommes donc très loin
des promesses du Conseil
interministériel de l'outreem du 6
novembre 2008 qui prévoyait la création
d'un cursus complet des études médicales
aux Antill guyan et souhaitait notamment
pour la Guyane faire de la santé une
activité de pote une fois de plus de
très Bones intentions mais qui sont
encore loin de se transformer en réalité
madame la ministre l'égalité devant les
soins ne serait-ce qu'un V
pie c'est la fin de ce débat si vous
souhaitez le revoir ou en savoir plus
sur ce thème notre site internet
publicsena.fr prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
c'est le 19h présenté ce soir par Michel
grossior très bonne fin de journée à
tous sur public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sénna